thanks [ __ ] buckers I have seen both
Deadpool's mm he'll be a bomb who have I
even live are they private house the
second one I love the second one okay
amazing but could I just say something
ask me question I am I'm sitting here
I'm do I know you probably hate
compliments but dude you are so [ __ ]
funny in those movies thank you saying I
am want to ask you something know what
about this why you just take something
take her out too many times
[ __ ] in the whole [ __ ] Deadpool
movies like there was a scene where Ryan
Reynolds his face is all [ __ ] up right
and you you said you say that his face
looks like an avocado yeah did you
improvise those lines so listen here's
the deal with Deadpool the writers are
[ __ ] brilliant both those guys are
amazing
and Paul Wernick he is like that both of
them are just [ __ ] they are so
specific they can tweak stuff so well
then Ryan Reynolds is like a really
brilliant she's a writer and improviser
yeah I think he got mad at me because I
teased him on hot ones I was kind of
making fun of how he's so funny
but he's so handsome and that gets in
the way so in covered up his beautiful
face yeah and then you didn't see him
and so everybody's able to understand
he's [ __ ] brilliant he's a little
spot he's a fast improviser very fast
but he throws lines as well as a writer
and then I'm an improviser by trade and
also a writer and so what that was was
that a combination of four people and
Tim Miller in the first one in david
leitch and the second one all kind of
throwing lines I guess it's like I've
never done anything with Judd Apatow
because I'm not interested in that
clique really but like I guess those
guys throw lines a lot like I'm homies
with Jay Baruchel and stuff so he said
that they they throw lines from you know
throw a line but we would all sort of
huddle up like I'll try this try this
right right but a lot of those like the
your face looks like Freddy Krueger
[ __ ] a topographical map you know such
as mine Kate gotta me
Peru in a rug form we have that in our
place in New York but yeah like it
certainly would be like your face looks
like an old or an avocado and I would be
like what if it's an older avocado
fuckton yeah yeah
so I sort of ribs same in Silicon Valley
I kind of about 30% of what I'm doing is
completely ripped and then I try and
bring something table but after about
let me ask you this because I because I
obviously I've done some stuff before
and yeah a lot of stuff I know but all
of it's been fun how right but the thing
is is that um you had one MADtv sketch
that I didn't care for it it's a little
bit racy for my taste these one was it
hey Gaby shut the [ __ ] up don't put them
on three oh and here's why
yeah yeah I don't even I don't like to
speak of it yeah but let me this is it
what are you is not in living color
where you read what you read you you you
do what's written and then you say to
the director can I get a pass yeah I
always do I can I get a pass that's what
I like save something that's stupid I'm
like can I get a pass you do not really
think of that the fact that I just did
that
no I'll sort of I always do it is
written for sure and I want to get it as
written in a way that they like and then
I'll just do if it's a joke slot I'll
just like throw lines over and over
until they say oh we've got it or let's
move on or sometimes I'll do like you
know I'll do I'll just like riff like a
line a line a line a line and then I'll
be like that the third one was great and
then I'll do that again
and then I'll do it again and I'm happy
with those three possible choices and
I'm like okay we got it let's move on
but I you know I'd say after a couple
movies people in town started understand
that if you hire me you're hiring
somebody who's not really gonna do the
lines like Michael Bay was really weird
about he it was such a strange thing
he's really is interesting strange like
really really sweet guy who [ __ ] is
crazy to work with I worked with him
before
what did you work with me physically
assaulted well I did a Pepsi commercial
[Music]